well you know shane gillis was on rogan
did you see him take a big swing and a
miss
no oh do you never seen this i saw it
too it dude it's
so funny so rowan's like so tell us like
how the senate
stuff came about he's doing it right and
he's going through it and rowan's like
uh-huh
and he goes yeah and then lauren you
know lauren uh michaels brought me into
his office
he's like we're gonna have to let you go
man and he and then
uh the camera's just on shane gillis and
he goes yeah someone
told me that i was like oh that's fine i
told him i'll just go on joe rogan
crickets cr i'm talking crickets and he
said he goes i'll just go on joe rogan
he likes to hit rooney goes
and he goes no not funny or wrong
okay dude it has to be the most awkward
moment
in jre joe help him out
dude he was like but the camera's not on
joe so it's like was joe just not paying
attention or
but i think joe was just like not buying
it like uh this isn't a real
he was just listening or yeah he was
like this
and then jane goes no
swinging on this damn and shane gillis
is a monster like he's a great
have you seen his stuff no i hear he's
gross dude he's an insane
hearing great things about him yeah he's
an insane comment great i'm so glad he's
doing his own sketch show now on on
youtube and
it's funny oh it's so funny it's so
funny
you haven't seen that i love hearing
that you haven't seen his been on trump
of speed dating
no oh yeah really it's
so [ __ ] good he's he's apparently the
real deal man yeah
yeah there's a reason why you know solid
guy who's gonna hire him good
he's a beast and and and what redemption
i'll do my
own sketch show yep yeah you know yeah
it's not saturday live
yeah i don't know if saturday night live
it's certainly not what it used to be
no it's definitely no it's definitely
not you what is what it is it's better
to have your own show on youtube
if it's your own show sketch show we're
all talking financially
name one person on saturday night live
just name one punky johnson pete
davidson
not anymore he's still on there he
hasn't landed yet pete davidson all
right yeah i don't know from saturday
night
you know him from the other stuff pete
davidson yeah i know from santa live
what other stuff yeah the point is we
don't talk about saturday night live the
way we used to do
no we don't talk about well but you
don't talk about any tv like that yeah
like
there's no show compared to seinfeld
better to have your own [ __ ] sketch
show on youtube
i disagree we're all talking about it no
no no we're talking about because i
brought up shane gilson no
that's not true i've heard i've had a
lot of people say it's a great show and
they talk about no that's a great show
is it bigger than saturday now listen
for him it's a better idea i think
for him it's it's it's redemption 100
i see what you're saying oh yeah i don't
i don't listen i love shane gillis i
know we're all about this
you know you think being on snl and
being the sex it's a much bigger deal
than having
your own show seventh cast member on snl
would be what he's an actual cast
what sell tickets not really dude i know
people who
i'm telling i also know people yeah
listen i'm not saying that he's gonna
sell tickets
you're crazy if you think doing a a skit
out of your
house is a bigger deal than be on
saturday night live in some ways i think
it is he has full creative control which
is great
financially it's not even close i don't
they don't make that much money
who does it people honest no neither
needed a sketch once a month on youtube
bubba
that may be true but and he's he's
liking millions of views so we got to
calm down a little
i know we're like anti-establishment
stuff like that
science life is a big deal it's a big
deal yeah
i mean it still does a lot for people
yeah you know
i mean i mean punky johnson just got our
own tv show well look at pete davidson
look at look at look at look at
[ __ ] uh i mean all those uh keenan
ivory wings there's just a lot of guys
there are a lot of alumni there are a
lot of people that have gone through
that machine
a lot who are not who are but that
doesn't mean it's not good
there's a lot that blew the [ __ ] i don't
know i see there are people yeah dude
there's like it's
not the same thing man i i no it's not
it's not as good
but what tv what tv is though compared
to back in the day
like there's so many outlets now yeah
but i i don't think we can sit here and
be like no he's better off doing out of
his house than being on saturday live
well i mean hopefully hopefully it gets
bigger to the point where he's making
millions dollars off that but
currently right now people like that are
just funny and they find their way
you know hopefully
uh just stuck with it he just stayed
what else would he do though
yeah was he gonna quit yeah i mean no he
just does stand up and
but he was funny on there he was like
well he's like
when people get canceled he's like
they're usually like famous already he's
like
i wasn't even famous he was like i was
just getting started and then he
cancelled me
he's like so it's a weird position to be
in is because like you know like
[ __ ] someone gets canceled they
usually find they have money they can do
other stuff he's like dude i
don't have [ __ ] i was broken
yeah yeah yeah his was different
he's very well liked though yeah people
everyone
yeah you talk to anyone he's like the
next big thing out of there [ __ ]
yeah cause those guys doing five six
sets a night man you know it's great and
it's just a great community it holds you
accountable we were on the
jfl new faces together and he did a bit
about uh